god of wisdom and win  precious twin boundary maker and  transgressor there is a problem with  your champion  i much prefer this vessel to that child  from danipan  i'm surprised and flattered to receive  your summons  emissary of descartes i would have  assumed you'd report directly to him  it is not my place to question the will  of the gods my master has entrusted me  to your employee for this task  and i shall serve you until this  catlipoca beats me return to his side  loyal indeed i must inform you  we have a problem your chosen pawn is  tainted by underworld energy  i worry there are interfering forces at  play his eyes are  [Music]  what  you